giorgos marque crise et sa famille se
sont installés ici en 2013
né à pollonia était alors une colonie de
vacances où les gens vivaient du
tourisme c'était avant la crise
économique a mis le chemin bien il y a
dix ans cet endroit était beau ça
grouillait d'activité il y avait du
travail
mais quand la crise des réfugiés a
frappé les affaires se sont détériorées
tout le monde cherche une solution
certains propriétaires d'hôtels
n'arrivait plus à l'or avec la crise ils
ont eu l'idée de louer leur propriété à
des réfugiés des familles vers l'est par
vagues successives
il a vu les visites dit les syriens les
africains s'installer dans les hôtels
vides de ses voisins depuis 2000 16
pièces un temps chaud pour lui avec sa
femme rollinat et leurs deux enfants ils
sont désormais les seuls grecque qui vit
encore ici parmi plus de 2000 demandeurs
d'asile les autorités lui ont offert une
maison en ville pour y vivre
meyer gosse refuse de partir puis je ne
peux tout simplement pas partir si je
partais il détruirait ma maison
complètement à côté ils sont entrés par
effraction ils ont retiré les portes
pour les brûler quand nous sommes venus
ici nous avons réussi à rénover la
maison pour en faire exactement ce qu'on
voulait vous n'arriverez pas à me faire
partir j'ai donné ma vie pour cette
maison
la cohabitation reste pogné avec la
majorité dit il et sa famille vit une
insécurité constante
la première vague qui est arrivé ce
n'était pas des musulmans s'était
dessaisi dit c'était différent plus
paisible
on arrivait à se parler pour régler nos
différends cas mais ils sont partis en
quelques mois plus tard ils ont amené
des gens de toutes les nationalités des
syriens des afghans c'est le chaos
maintenant il y à des bagarres beaucoup
de crimes et personne ne nous aide nous
avions la police avant mais ils ont
fermé le poste le plus proche est
maintenant à 35 kilomètres d'ici
l'insécurité et la peur beaucoup des
familles étrangères qui habitent les
petites chambres dans les hôtels tout
autour la ressentent aussi il tente de
naviguer un processus bureaucratique
qu'ils comprennent souvent très mal dans
la crainte d'être finalement renvoyé
d'où ils viennent ni cousins gaulois
instinct ou que ce qu'ils ont fui les
rattrape
jusqu'ici haddonfield ces fiers réel et
je ne me sens pas en sécurité ici je ne
sors pas de ma chambre j'ai vécu des
choses terribles en afghanistan avait
passé les battre ce qu'on souhaite
cacher son visage de peur d'être
reconnue elle n'arrive pas à retenir ses
larmes quand elle pense à ce qui
l'attend si elle devait retourner dans
son pays
mais parce que je suis une fille et que
j'allais l'unversité je faisais du sport
j'avais un travail je sortais de la
maison et ça dérangeait on me disait
qu'une fille ne pouvait pas faire ça
partir laisser ma famille et mes amis a
été très difficile mais je ne peux pas
imaginer retourner en afghanistan
ces gens là les talibans vont au dessus
je le sais zara est arrivé seul en grèce
en 2017 après avoir tenté 17 fois de
traverser la mer depuis la turquie
c'est ici qu'elle a rencontré akram un
afghan lui aussi qui est devenu son mari
le couple a maintenant une fillette
sahara c'est toute une vie qu'ils se
sont bâtis en attendant le traitement de
leurs dossiers
il y a quelques semaines ils ont chacun
été rejetée comme réfugiés par les
autorités ils attendent maintenant de
pouvoir en appeler de cette décision
pour éviter d'être déportés
depuis son arrivée au pouvoir l'été
dernier le gouvernement de droite ne
cache pas son intention d'être plus
stricts sur l'octroi de l'asile en grèce
l'objectif est de renvoyer en turquie
dix mille demandeurs d'asile déboutés
cette année un peu plus loin sur la côte
les hôteliers donné à grasse n'a
profitent des mois calmes divers et des
plages désertes pour retaper leur
propriété pour la saison à venir et se
reposer certains ont choisi de louer
leurs chambres vides pour y loger des
demandeurs d'asile un geste qui a
suscité la colère de nombreux collègues
qui craignent de devenir un nouveau né à
apollonia elina possède une petite
auberge qui accueille des touristes
l'été nikkei mot steelers dans nos
médias
on nous traite injustement surtout ici
année à brazza
ils nous présentent comme des racistes
et des xénophobes
on nous insulte ça nous a blessés pour
le moment cette taxe par la police et
faut dit elle la population ne cherche
qu'à se protéger on les voit se balader
des hommes célibataires qui arrive de
turquie combien viendront sont ils tous
des réfugiés
nous avons perdu le contrôle et n'avons
aucune idée de ce qui se passe tout le
monde a fermé ses frontières sauf nous
nous mêmes les grecs partons pour
l'étranger pour trouver du travail et ce
immigrants viennent ici ils vivent
gratuitement sans devoir travailler
cette résistance populaire compromet le
plan annoncé en septembre dernier de
déplacer les dizaines de milliers de
migrants en attente sur les îles de la
mer egée dans des conditions
désastreuses en grèce continentale d'ici
l'été
certains demandeurs d'asile dont la
situation a été jugée prioritaire ont pu
quitter lesbos ils vivent maintenant
dans des camps comme celui ci avaya
rouler
les conteneurs sont plus spacieux chacun
logent deux familles et surtout des
enfants ont accès à une éducation
ok nous explique notre peau neuve
j'ai été surpris par le niveau de leurs
connaissances pour être honnête je ne
m'y attendais pas surtout les égyptiens
ça dépend aussi du temps qu'ils ont pu
passer à l'école certains n'y vont plus
depuis des années chacun d'eux porte sa
propre histoire
ils font de moi une meilleure personne
si vous ne puissiez voter
le maire de la municipalité devolvé qui
englobe née à grasse n'a est né à
pollonia diamantis llamas dit compatir
avec les demandeurs d'asile comme ses
concitoyens précisé crois que les
villages de sa municipalité suffisamment
contribué à mettre à l'abri stucco la
solidarité devrait être la qualité
première de l'union européenne mais ce
n'est pas ce qu'on voit de la part des
peuples et des gouvernements
cette année en ligue 1 avant de leur
jeter la pierre les pays de l'europe
ajoute ils doivent aussi partager le
fardeau